the Quran says that what's his name
Ahmed is mentioned in theil right well
actually it doesn't it doesn't say Ahmed
is mentioned in the or it's mentioned in
it says Jesus said it says Jesus
mentioned right right right and now
you're left with two options either
you're left with the option of if this
is the case then the gospel the mark
Matthew and John didn't write it down if
that's the case right we're assuming and
if it's if it's the case that they did
write it down then it's so if we're The
quran's Narrative no that's not it at
all no if we're going well you're asking
me where does it would mean that if we
do not find in the gospel Jesus
mentioning Aid to come then the Quran
lied hello hi what's up man what's up
are you Muslim yeah welcome so you asked
what is the in it's what was revealed to
Jesus what was that what was that what
was revealed to him yeah well the
specifics we don't know but we know it
was the General message of one of God
how do you know that because the Quran
tells us that the Quran tells you that
that's what's in the angel or is that
the Quran tells you that Jesus said that
no the Quran tells us that all the
prophets received the same message
roughly so so then how do you know that
okay so did all the prophets receive the
NGO no when did I say that he didn't but
that's my point is that if you're saying
that all the prophets received the same
message I didn't say not exact not exact
well you did you just said that Jesus
they said roughly the same message okay
so maybe we's just start over what was
in theel okay the specifics as in like
the exact laws we do not know however we
know that the general message of it was
the was theed the Oneness of God right
because of the the Quran tells us that
what does the Quran tell you that the in
the the general message was T here let
me search up now remember I'm not asking
where does Jesus himself say worship one
Lord and your Lord my God you know y I'm
not saying that I'm asking where does it
say that that's the that's the same
concept because whatever Jesus speaks of
is revelation and the Revelation is the
inel whatever Jesus said is inil if he's
speaking in regards to religion yeah
where is I'm confused is whatever Jesus
says the in or not in regards to
religion like if Jesus says today is
Friday that's not theil right that's not
because it's not a revelation how do you
know that because it's not something
that needs to be revealed a revelation
is something that needs to be revealed
well so like for example Pharaoh the
Quran records Pharaoh claiming that he
was God right okay we we already know
this this was in the Bible this was in
history everyone already knew that
Pharaoh claimed to be God no but the
reason why he repeats old Stories the
prophet in the Quran or Allah repeats
old stories in the Quran is we have
records of people asking for example the
story of the people in the cave they
said the Jews came to said if you are
truthful tell me about this
story where does where does the Quran
show say that people were asking about
pharaoh and what happened with them the
Quran never specifically mentions that
we go by outside sources okay where in
the outside source does it say that
people were asking specifically about
the story of Moses and therefore that's
why Allah recounted it in the no this is
to be assumed because I gave you the
reference of the do you if you want I
can give you the reference of the Jews
coming and asking the prophet if you are
a truthful Prophet tell me about the
story of the people in the cave that's
because they knew they was playing games
with him they're playing games with him
but how does that but dude showing
showing an example where one time people
ask him about a certain thing doesn't
mean that that's the case for all times
of all Revelation okay so what exactly
is your point my point is that the basis
for what you don't have a basis for what
you're saying like what you're saying
about how you know
what Jesus said is revelation and what
isn't you don't have a basis to judge
that so in your argument what is theel
to you uh I have it it's in my gospels
okay so you think do you think your
gospels are preserved yeah okay do you
have a Bible do you disagree I have I
have you disagree that I have the in I
disagree that you have a preserved Bible
I don't for that do you disagree do you
agree or disagree that I have the I
disagree you don't have it okay how do
you know that I don't have the in
because you have words of Mark Luke John
and Matthew the Quran never mentions
that okay so who did write the angel
then it's not a written book the Quran
says it is no no no when the Quran
refers as aab a book it's referring to
Revelation the Quran wasn't originally
written was it when it was when it was
you're over no no no when the Quran was
being revealed to the Propet I'm trying
to help you bro I'm not I'm trying to
help you let me let me speak when the I
am I'm trying to I'm serious I don't
mean to cut you off I'm trying to help
you the I'm not talking about how it
refers to it as aab I'm saying that the
Quran literally says that the inil was
written Mak where does it say it was
written down on a or something 7 verse
157 see 157 yes sir where does it say it
was written it says they are the ones
who follow the messenger the unlettered
prophet whose description they find in
their Torah and their the gospel you see
where it says description yeah the word
is not description the word is written
which in Arabic is Makin I got you I got
you we I trust the Arabic speakers so
watch just watch okay you trust
quran.com yeah I'm on it right now
Perfect You're on.com why don't you
hover over the word Makin the word for
description why don't you hover over it
I don't even got to do it you can see it
yourself okay I see you see how written
but how does this prove preservation of
it it proves that the that the inil is a
written document now my question is now
so look your your accusation against the
New Testament or the gospel that I have
that I don't have the ngel is because
what I have was written by Matthew Mark
Luke and John and you're saying that the
Quran doesn't mention them so I asked
you in turn then who wrote it so of
course he was like oh it's not written
so now we know that it's written so now
we're going back to the original
question who wrote the NG okay then in
this case I would just say we don't have
the written one we don't know who wrote
it all right so how do you know that
Matthew Mark Luke and John didn't write
the N well we know that even if well
first of all these are like Anonymous
names we don't really know much about
these people second of all so then we
can't really say Mark wrote this who is
Mark this just a name right I I I
disagree but however going with your
point that still doesn't answer the
question let's say even these people are
Anonymous the reason the reason we know
that the original writers who wrote this
in Gil right they their written
documents aren't with us today is
because when we look at the preservation
of it the earliest complete gospels we
find or near complete are 400 years
after Jesus and the earliest fragments
which are like credit card size are 200
years after Jesus do they what we do
they match what I have today even though
you're wrong but do they match what I
have today in your Bible probably not
they don't do you have John 57 in your
Bible wait you just you just matched
codex caticus you you you just that does
codex does what I have match codex
anticus I don't know what Bible you're
using do you have John 5 just answer the
question bro it depends on the Bible
you're using yeah so notice how the
notice the dishonesty you can't even be
it's wait can you answer me okay can you
answer no cuz what you're doing is
you're trying to do the Muslim Shuffle
and Shuffle away it's not so so how
about so how about we do this let's
let's let's do this thing you said that
Matthew Mark Luke and John are Anonymous
is that a reason why you can't trust the
gospel No actually that's not the main
reason I wouldn't trust it wait I didn't
say m is that a reason why you don't
trust the gospel I well in personally
are you asking generally or personally
I'm asking you no that wouldn't be a
necessarily reason okay so with the NGO
you didn't still answer me how you know
Matthew Mark Luke and John didn't write
the I told you that it doesn't to me it
doesn't really matter if they did or
they didn't well that's what you brought
up because you said first of all Matthew
marugan we know that it's not the ngel
because your gospel was written by
Matthew Mark Luke and John while in the
Quran it doesn't mention them therefore
what you have is not the NGO that's the
first thing you brought up okay I was
referring to this is the the reason I
brought this up is because theil is
referred to as the gospel not plural so
it's not it's not gospels so it can't it
can't but if you're asking without the
Quran if you're asking me no no it's
okay stick with the Quran how many how
many books are in the Torah I don't know
the exact I think the I know the old
testament's five right the Torah
contains five books okay is the Torah
singular or plural in the Quran or in
general the the word Torah in the Quran
anywhere singular very good so the word
Torah is singular yet it is made up of a
plurality of books right but you don't
refer to the gospels as a gospel you
refer to as gospels no we we refer to it
as the gospel matter of fact uh the
church tradition they used to call it
the fourfold gospel so so it could be
referred to either or it could be
referred to as the gospel the gospels or
the fourfold gospel we say gospel all
the time so you're saying that the Quran
mentioning a singularity here isn't
relevant is that what you're saying the
Quran using the singular form of the
word gospel means nothing because it
uses it uses the singular form of the
word Torah although the Torah is made up
of Five Books Okay so if theel is
referring to what was originally giving
to Jesus and I and I say yes it was
written how and you said you have theel
so how do you know that what you have
now is what was written flipping it on
me again we're still back on this on the
same question well it all ties back to
the Rel ility of the
Bible back to say that again all of it
ties back to the reliability of the
Bible no it doesn't you said no so I'm
I'm just I'm just showing you how your
reasoning for rejecting the gospel that
we have today is faulty because you
believe the same things about theel for
example Matthew Mark Luke and John you
said are the writers of the Gospel
supposedly and so therefore it's not the
because the Quran doesn't mention them
so how but you don't know who wrote the
so my question still stands how do you
know that Matthew Mark Luke and John
didn't write the inel I already answered
that I told you I don't know but I don't
see it as a relevant question okay all
right so how about this then because
it's relevant here's the reason why it's
relevant it's relevant because it was
the first thing you brought up for your
reasoning why I don't have the inil
because your reasoning was the inil was
not written by Matthew Mark Luke and
John my gospel is therefore theel and my
gospel are not the same thing but now
we're at the point where actually you
don't know who wrote the ngel it could
have been Matthew Mark Luke and John who
knows so then that reasoning to reject
my gospel is out the window fair enough
okay fair enough so now let's go on to
do we have the the Bible that we have
now is it the same Bible that was
written at the time of Jesus or shortly
after Jesus well actually we go back to
the original question because remember
you asked me if I have the NG I said yes
my question was how do you know I don't
have it how do you know well this whole
ties back to the reliability of the
Bible no how so because the angel is
still described as what was given to
Jesus right and Jesus was born or Jesus
lived in the first century so if we
don't have what was in the first century
then we don't have the interesting did
the Jew did the Christians in the sixth
Century have the Ino the original Ino no
did they have the in geop because the
Quran doesn't mention in original or not
original it just mentions in geop period
it mentions
okay where does it mention a corrupted
inel it says woe to those who write
scripture with their own hands and say
has nothing to do with theel how then
what is this referring to it's actually
referring to some of the Jews who write
books with their own hands in regards to
their Torah by putting it on the same
Lev as the Torah the Christians are not
mentioned anywhere in that text nor is
the inil the whole context is about the
Torah and some of some of what some of
the Jews are so your claims that nowhere
in the Quan doesn't make does it say
it's very simple the Quran says that
what's his name Ahmed is mentioned in
the inil right well actually it doesn't
it doesn't say Ahmed is mentioned in the
or it's mentioned in it says Jesus said
it says Jesus mentioned right right
right and now you're left with two
options either you left with the option
of if this is the case then the gospel
the mark Matthew and John didn't write
it down if that's the case right we're
assuming and if it's if it's the case
that they did write it down then it's so
if we're The quran's Narrative no that's
not it at all no if we're going well
you're asking me where does it would
mean that if we do not find in the
gospel Jesus mentioning Aid to come then
the Quran lied no no no but you're
asking based off the Quran right so
you're presupposing yeah you're saying
where does the Quran say that well
that's based off your belief right so if
you're asking based off my belief right
and your Miss you're missing it you're
missing it the only time I'm referencing
the
is when you bring up excuse me when you
bring up reasoning that backfires
against you okay that's the reason why
I'm I'm bringing up the Quran so if you
don't bring up you know reasoning that
back back bites you I won't even I don't
have a problem with bring I don't I can
leave the Quran alone if you're being
consistent you know no you're missing my
point right you're you're asking me
where the Quran says that the NGO is
corrupted yeah you're a Muslim you right
so if if I'm going off my konic belief
then the Quran would force me to the Bel
that the was corrupted that's the
argument I'm bring okay no no no see
what the Quran would do is the Quran
would force you to believe that the
Quran itself is false because the Quran
affirms the injil says the inil is
preserved and reliable and is accessible
and when we go into the injil as the
Quran says we should find Muhammad and
when we do that and we don't find
Muhammad then the Quran is false so the
Quran forces you
to know that the Quran is false you
asked me earlier where in the Quran does
it say the was corrupted right and then
now you're saying that the Quran says
the inel was preserved and what was the
other word use you said the
Rel you ask for a word for word
basically so where in the Quran where in
the Quran is there a word for word that
the inil is reliable and trustworthy so
I didn't ask you for word for word
that's what you were no I'm asking you
to prove in
what you say yeah and I'm giving my
reasoning based off the Quran and you're
just saying and I ref it no no no
because you're you're I'm saying that
from the Quran it would force me to the
belief that the angel is corrupted and
you're saying no that just means the
Quran is false right that doesn't that's
an argument you're just presupposing
it's false based off that I'm not
presupposing it it's the logical
conclusion if the Quran makes a claim
look if the Quran makes a claim right
and then we see that the claim is false
then the Quran is false no no no no
absence of evidence is not evidence
absence right just because you don't see
it if the Quran makes a claim and says I
can go in this source and find something
and I don't that means that there's no
evidence for what the Quran say actually
the evidence works against the Quran so
there's evidence that the Quran is false
no no no you yourself said that Jes it
it didn't say in theil it was Ahmed it
says Jesus said but you but you yourself
said that everything Jesus said in
regards to religion is in no I said it's
Revelation which is in right some some
of it maybe some of it's not just like
no don't change now you said that
everything that said regarding is the
inal because it's Revelation then I
changed my mind wait you just changed it
just now yeah because I realized I mean
it's it makes sense actually because in
the Quran you have the same thing not
every oh man it's the same thing so wait
so there's things about there's things
in the Quran that's you know that's not
Revelation there's Revelation that's not
in the CR okay okay so you're saying
that oh so you're saying that Jesus
mentioning op may be in the in the
Hadith of Jesus no what I'm saying that
it the Hadith is just a compilation or
someone a saying of someone so in that
sense if you want to say that's what the
Hadith means then sure you can go with
that but we don't have the Hadith right
okay is there do you have Revelation
that Jesus gave that exists outside of
the Quran
Revelation sorry excuse me do you have
Revelation that Jesus revealed right
that is outside of the inel I'm of theil
I would assume so yeah because the Quran
follows the same line of logic where do
you get this from that there's
Revelation from Jesus that is outside of
the Ino where do you get that from
because please don't make it up where do
you get that from because I'm ask you to
show me so in the Quran you have
Revelation giv to the prophet that is
not in the so we can suppose that the
same is in the case of Jesus why because
it's just if you have there's no reason
to think not that's why yeah the reason
the thing not is that we don't have that
anywhere so why would you assert that
there is this thing this imaginary
source that has Jesus's Revelation once
again absence of evidence is not
evidence of absence I mean even in your
own Bible okay how about this how about
this you one second you agree that in
your own Bible can I can I just can I
just then since you do not have evidence
to back up your claim and assertion then
I can just dismiss your claim without
evidence but you're asking me what my
belief is no I didn't ask for Bel I ask
for I'm asking for fact in what is not
what you think what you believe so if
you're asking for fact of what is in the
Quran and you don't believe in the Quran
say what in the is fact again here was
my question my question was is there not
do you think there is do you believe no
is there is there Revelation from Jesus
that's not in the ngel I have no way to
prove that there was or wasn't so then
why would you even suggest the other
because because because there is more
reason to believe that there is and
there is you have no reason to believe
it I just I just gave you the reason
with the nothing to do with the if the
last prophet had Revelation outside of
the Quran then we can suppose that Jesus
had this had Revelation outside of why
because we have no reason to think
otherwise you have no reason you have no
reason to think wise you have no reason
to think wise that is the reason the
reason is that they share similarity so
you guys could just make up stuff I like
that y'all can just make up stuff make
up stuff and that's cool that's cool
it's all right I can make up you can
make up stuff and you gotta just take it
and I got to take it as fact I can make
up stuff and back when I asked you right
in the Bible you would agree that the
gospel writers themselves said we are
not able to write everything that Jesus
said no did said it's an action the same
it's the same in the same sense it's not
the same so you're saying every single
word Jesus said the gospels wrote down
every single one but in regards to
Revelation yeah okay why is it that I'm
the father of one is only found in John
why didn't mark write that down because
that's not the account that he wrote
down so only joh what does that what
does that have to do with anything
because it's showing that they don't
they didn't write everything they saw
down they themselves said they didn't
write everything but hold on saying that
one writer writes something that another
writer didn't to then conclude that
therefore we don't have everything that
Jesus said and revealed is faulty how do
you conclude that can help me bring it
to
conclusion if if Mark doesn't write down
what John says therefore we don't have
all of what Jesus said it ties back to
the it ties back to the Bible verse that
says we cannot write everything that
Jesus did that has nothing to do with
that it does again please help me out it
Mark wrote wrote down an account John
wrote things that Mark didn't mark wrote
things that John didn't how does that
equal missing some things that Jesus
revealed because once again it shows
you're telling me that John the only
witness there is that what you're trying
to tell me he's the only one that
accounted it what's the problem he's the
only one that witnessed it how does that
prove how does that there's things that
Jesus reveal that we're missing oh don't
say counted it because now you're in
dangerous territory because if Mar
counted it and he didn't write it then
you see see no notice how you can't deal
with any argument why are you running
away you see do you see this you can't
even conclude what you did you hear what
you just said so I'm challenge you to
finish the to to finish the syllogism
prove the conclusion you said John wrote
things down that Jesus revealed that
Mark didn't therefore we don't have all
the revelation of Jesus and I I need you
to link that make conclusion so let me
speak now let me speak now right I asked
you afterwards are you saying John is
the only one who witnessed it you said
that he is he is the only one who wrote
it down that's what you said correct
what did you say that's correct now
please answer the conclusion so he's the
only okay so do you believe he's the
only one who witnessed asking me another
question does not substantiate your
conclusion because it gets me gets me to
the point if I'm just make CLA you're
just going to say no you're just
repeating yourself I need you because
notice how I was able to repeat your
argument and now I'm asking for you to
substantiate your conclusion right do
you do that for me do just do it just do
it okay look logic look this is how it
is the reason why the reason why M
Matthew writing something that John
didn't or John writing something that
Mark didn't equals mean
that we are missing a revelation that
Jesus gave is because is because it
proves that some of the gospel writers
didn't write down what they had
witnessed the reason why this proves it
is because you are making the Absurd
claim that only John witnessed Jesus
claiming to be I and the father at one
such a huge claim only John witnessed it
that is insane that is insan let me ask
let me ask you a question based on this
conclusion then we're going to move on
because you still are not substantiating
if if Mark doesn't say something that
John does does that mean that we are
missing something that Jesus said it it
it shows that there is room for missing
verses no no no does that mean I didn't
ask him what does that mean that we are
missing something that Jesus said that
he the evidence points to it yes if
you're asking for 100% so it's just it's
just more assertions and just more
claims bro you want I'm talking to a guy
who just make anything on the spot no
substantiation no proof no anything you
you could just say whatever you want how
can you even have a conversation I'm
telling you the evidence points to it
what evidence again what evidence for
example for example for example if if if
if I am accounting what we our
conversation and you are accounting our
conversation and let's say let's say I
wrote I I marked down something in our
conversation that you happened to not
You didn't mark it down you didn't
record it in your writing in your
account of our does that mean that what
was said between us is now missing that
there's something
in analogy let me give you a more
accurate no just answer the question
please no no no no that is an absurd
analogy it's an absurd analogy it
doesn't apply